foreign
s in the universe Earth is clearly the
best for life right
wrong
Earth may be great but scientists have
discovered a few worlds that could be
even better for life
behold koi 5715.01
most of the contenders on our super
habitable planet list aren't the ones
you could visit anytime soon they are
very far away
the top spot is held by one 3 000 light
years away from our solar system
koi 575.01 would appear to satisfy the
most basic requirement for supporting
life
it exists in the Goldilocks zone of its
star
so conditions wouldn't be too hot or too
cold for a key life supporting
ingredient to exist on its surface
liquid water
but it would also check off many boxes
to be considered super habitable
the planetary system it belongs to could
be five and a half billion years old
which would make it around 1 billion
years older than our own solar system
and the planet would almost fit the size
requirement
when looking for super habitable worlds
scientists keep their eyes peeled for
planets that have a mass up to one and a
half times of our planet and they should
be about 10 percent larger too
this size difference would help the
planet retain heat and if its average
temperature was about 5 degrees Celsius
higher than Earth's well this planet
could have even richer biodiversity
now being almost double the size of
Earth koi 571 5.01 might overshoot this
condition a bit
besides studies indicate that this
planet is actually colder than Earth
but there's still hope with the right
atmospheric composition a strong
greenhouse effect could raise
temperatures to the desired level and as
far as super habitable worlds go well
we're just getting started
approximately 2 700 light years away is
Kepler 69c
this super Earth could be around 7
billion years old
this puts it perfectly in the estimated
five to eight billion year old age range
for super habitable planets this range
is based on the three and a half billion
years it took for a complex life to
appear on Earth
so the best chance for finding life
could be on a planet a little older than
us
only this exoplanet could be a little
too big to be super habitable it has a
mass almost four times that of Earth
a rocky planet this big could have a
single colossal continent that would
have huge deserts in its Center
but the coastline Washed by Kepler's
ocean could be your perfect spot to move
to
our next Super Earth shares a similar
name Kepler 1126b except it would be
located ever so slightly closer to home
yeah this planet is about
2073 light years away and it belongs to
a system that is seven and a half
billion years old
it also orbits a yellow dwarf star much
like our own only Kepler 1126b is two
and a half times closer to its star than
Earth is to the Sun but that's no big
deal because the star Kepler 1126b
orbits is cooler than ours so the
habitable zone would exist in a Range
much closer in proximity to it
if you aren't feeling this nearness to a
scorching hot star there's another Super
Earth on our list and it's at a
reasonable distance from home
speculos 2C is located only 106 light
years away
not that its proximity gives it any kind
of advantage
it would still take you well over 200
000 years to travel to this super Earth
and that's if you moved at the speed of
NASA's Parker solar probe the fastest
probe ever launched
speculos 2C does look promising though
it's about 40 percent larger than Earth
there's also the potential for it being
a rocky planet just like ours
now despite the fact that it also exists
in a habitable zone it's red dwarf star
is still very small
it's only about 15 percent the size of
our sun
so this planet orbits around its star at
a very close distance
and this close distance could mean that
speculos 2C is tidally locked to its
star
this super Earth takes eight and a half
days to make one full rotation on its
axis as well as one orbit around its
star
that would leave one side of the planet
in constant daylight and the other in
Endless Night
this means that life could be possible
in The Terminator Zone
the thin strip of land between the two
sides we just need to get a better look
to find out for sure
[Music]
thank you
635 light years from where you are
sitting
way out there in outer space lies a
planet
the first planet to be discovered within
the habitable zone of a sun-like star
its name is Kepler-22b
when a planet is located within a star's
habitable zone it means there's a chance
that liquid water exists on its surface
and where there's water there's also the
possibility of life
human life
how long would it take to get to Kepler
22b
what would the weather be like over
there
and why would you need to get jacked
before arriving on this new planet
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you live on Kepler-22b
Kepler-22b is what scientists call an
exoplanet it's a planet outside our
solar system
spotting an exoplanet like Kepler-22b is
often not easy
the bright glare of the Stars they orbit
tends to keep them hidden from our
telescopes
what did scientists come up with to get
around it
looking at the stars themselves to see
if they can find anything unusual about
them they spotted Kepler-22b using
What's called the transit method
they watched Kepler 22 the star this
exoplanet orbits around and noticed that
its brightness changes over time that
was because
Kepler-22b was blocking the star's light
with this scientists were able to learn
both the size of 22b and how it orbits
and it looks like this distant Space
Rock could become our next home
okay but what do we really know about
Kepler-22b
its mass is 36 times that of Earth with
a radius of two and a half times larger
than ours one year on Kepler-22b is 290
days
it's also located 15 percent closer to
its star than we are to the Sun
if Earth scooched over that close to our
star
you'd be fried
Kepler-22b on the other hand is lucky to
have a son that is remarkably similar to
ours but also smaller and cooler this
close proximity to its star allows the
planet to receive about the same amount
of sunlight as we get over here
the temperature on Kepler-22b could be
about 15 to 22 degrees Celsius
similar to Earth's Spring weather and
quite habitable if you ask me
but our galaxy can be a cruel place and
not everything is good news
some models suggest Kepler-22b is
rotating on its side kind of like our
very own Uranus
this may sound insignificant but it adds
potentially deadly complications this
would mean that it's North and South
poles are shrouded in either Darkness or
sunlight for half a year
and this ain't simply a matter of
whether you're a daytime or a nighttime
person a world like Kepler-22b spinning
on its side means that temperatures
could change from boiling to freezing
which wouldn't be great for human life
I know what a bummer but don't despair
yet because our galaxy is also big
enough to include some hope
studies suggest that Kepler-22b might be
covered in an ocean 50 meters deep and
that ocean would be able to act as
natural climate control keeping the wild
temperatures at Bay
you see an ocean can store heat in the
summer and release it during the winter
which results in a mild climate like you
needed another reason to live close to
the water
but hold on how would you even make it
all the way to Kepler-22b I mean even if
you were traveling at the speed of light
it would take you
635 years
your best bet could be to hibernate
through the trip inside a device that
preserves your body way past its natural
lifespan like cryogenic sleep
NASA has already developed a cryosleep
chamber that can lower an astronaut's
body temperature to as low as 32 degrees
Celsius
this would trigger natural hibernation
during which catheters would provide
your body with nutrients and remove any
waste
but even in cryosleep it would be quite
the long risky trip this leads us to the
most dangerous part about this journey
All That Remains Unknown about
Kepler-22b
for starters we still don't really know
what gravity is like there it could be
twice as strong as our planets if that
was the case a 10 kilogram sack of
potatoes would now weigh 20 kilograms
and your body would also factor into the
mix
is your current weight 75 kilograms well
good luck suddenly dealing with 150
kilograms of you
and just for safety settlers such as
yourself would need to bulk up really
bulk up
only through intense strength training
would you increase your chances of being
able to walk on Kepler-22b and once you
got jacked on Earth you'd have to figure
out ways to preserve that muscle through
all
635 years of light speed travel
but humans aren't the only life form
that would be affected by a stronger
gravity
plants brought from Earth for oxygen and
nutrition might not survive on
Kepler-22b when you try growing them
there and if you brought any animals
with you they'd need to step up the
evolution process
higher gravity could lead to creatures
developing additional legs to move
around it could also determine the
location and size of internal organs
but the Mysteries don't end there
scientists still don't know for sure
that Kepler-22b is even a rocky planet
it might be gaseous similar to Neptune
or it could be entirely covered with
water
if you and the other first settlers woke
up from your cryo sleep and found
yourself on a gas planet
yeah that would be a downer
you wouldn't have a solid surface to
even land your ship not to mention a
place to set up camp
in that case you and your crew would
need to figure out how to build a cloud
city orbiting the planet
if you landed on an ocean planet a
submarine town would be in order
discovering Kepler-22b is a rocky planet
would be hitting the jackpot then right
well not so fast Venus is also made of
rock and yet its dense atmosphere
consisting of greenhouse gases makes it
uninhabitable with scorching
temperatures far too hot for liquid
water
if this was also the situation with
Kepler-22b our only chance at thriving
on this exoplanet would be to employ
robots that could build underground
shelters the place where maybe just
maybe the temperature might be cool
enough for you to bear
it just goes to show you that a prime
location is no guarantee for human
survival and as exciting as it might
seem to find other worlds to inhabit our
own Earth Remains the perfect Habitat
for Humanity
this is a planetary emergency evacuation
please remain calm and board your space
shuttles
you know even though Humanity might not
have to leave the Earth in your lifetime
we should start preparing early on
not only could it take centuries to set
up the relocation program
it would take generations to move to a
potential new home
that right there is Proxima Centauri b
or just Proxima B
it's the closest potentially habitable
planet out there
its temperatures are in the bearable
range and it could have just the right
breathable atmosphere
we only have to get there
how long would our journey last
how many people would we send to
populate the new world successfully
and what if it turned out that Proxima B
wasn't as habitable as we thought
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we relocated Humanity to
Proxima B
when astronomers started finding planets
outside our solar system or exoplanets
we realized that there are many worlds
out there
that meant that Earth doesn't have to be
our home forever
and that we don't have to die with our
planet when the sun engulfs in some five
billion years from now
[Music]
that we've found over 4 100 exoplanets
we've learned something rather
disappointing
not all exoplanets are good for humans
to live on
most of the worlds we've encountered are
either ice giants like Neptune or gas
giants like Jupiter and Saturn
only 161 of those planets are
terrestrial like Earth
and when it comes to sustaining human
life
being terrestrial isn't quite enough
Proxima B is very promising it orbits a
red dwarf star called Proxima Centauri
in a system with three stars in it
Proxima Centauri is small
it only has between seven and a half and
fifty percent of our son's Mass
that's a good thing because the Red
Dwarf Proxima Centauri is so much
smaller than our yellow dwarf Sun
it burns at a lower temperature
it takes stars like Proxima Centauri
much longer to burn through all of their
hydrogen Supply
because of that Proxima Centauri has a
lifetime of trillions of years while our
sun has a 10 billion year expiration
term
that alone makes Proxima b a good
candidate for relocation
that and the fact that its orbit lies in
Proxima centauri's habitable zone
that means there's the potential for
liquid water and comfortable surface
temperatures
if we're lucky Proxima B would have an
atmosphere that we could breathe
if it does the surface temperatures
would be in the range of 30 degrees
I don't know about you but I'd move
there right now
I just need to warn you that there are a
few problems
a trip to Proxima B would be long and
very dangerous
Proxima B might be the closest habitable
exoplanet we've got but that doesn't
mean it's close
the red dwarf star Proxima Centauri is
about 4.3 light years away
that means that if you could travel at
the speed of light it would take you 4.3
years to get there
nothing we've built so far can reach
that kind of speed
realistically a trip to Proxima Centauri
in a space shuttle would take 165
000 years
give or take
that's right some of the colonists would
be born in transit
some of them would never see the Earth
some of them would never see Proxima B
they'd just live their lives aboard the
spaceship and die in space
how many humans would we need to send on
a mission exactly
[Music]
well according to some calculations 98
people would be just enough
their descendants would arrive at
Proxima B with enough genetic diversity
to populate the entire planet
and that's accounting for possible cases
of infertility inbreeding and sudden
deaths
in those calculations the crew would be
traveling on something faster than a
space shuttle
their mission to Proxima B would only
take 6 300 years
but don't be surprised technology is
constantly improving
right now a scientific and technological
program called breakthrough initiatives
is looking at how we can get in the
neighborhood of Proxima Centauri within
one generation
their project starshot is working on an
ultralight unmanned probe that would
reach the star system in just 20 years
now I definitely need to sign up
but again Proxima B is really far away
it's so far that we can't even see if it
has an atmosphere
it might just happen that we would
arrive at a frozen planet with surface
temperatures of minus 40 degrees
and even if it has an atmosphere it
might not be the right one
we might still enjoy warm temperatures
but we'd be doing that in spacesuits
with oxygen tanks
or Proxima B could be tidally locked to
Proxima Centauri meaning that one of the
planet's sides would always face its
star and the other side would be plunged
Into Darkness
space flight itself could bring some
unpleasant surprises
spending an entire lifetime in a zero
gravity environment would lead the crew
members to lose muscle and bone density
they'd be constantly exposed to space
radiation
their microbiomes immune systems and
Physiology would all be different from
ours
they wouldn't be the same kind of humans
as we are
they would change their values and
culture
they might forget all the farming
techniques we'd teach them to sustain
themselves in space and on their new
planet
they might change their mind about the
mission altogether and just turn their
spaceship in a different direction
who knows they might even come back to
earth and take revenge for all those
years they were forced to spend in space
if that happens I'll be asking for a
refund
sending anyone on a mission like this is
a huge risk
we'd need to design and build a vehicle
choose the space Travelers very
carefully
Supply them with all the food and water
and make sure they could become
self-sustaining
we'd have to design new propulsion
navigation hibernation and life support
systems and we have no way of knowing if
Proxima B is actually habitable
well now I don't really feel like going
there do you
[Music]
just north of the Martian equator lies
of 45 kilometer wide impact crater that
scientists believe may have been the
site of an ancient Lake here at jazero
Crater scientists theorize that it's
frozen soil may contain the most
significant discovery of humankind
life
on February 18
2021 NASA's perseverance Rover started
searching this crater to find out if
we're truly alone
what is the likelihood of Life on Mars
what would these Martians look like
and how will we send samples back to
Earth
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we discovered Life on Mars
as Scientific American puts it it would
take a near miracle for Mars to be
sterile
astrobiologist Chris McKay at Nasa
believes that Earth and Mars have been
sharing materials for billions of years
kind of like using your roommate's spice
rack
what I thought you said it was communal
comets or large meteorites that have hit
Earth may have also sent debris onto
Mars
a tiny fraction of this debris on Mars
could have carried the same microbes
that kick-started Life as We Know It On
Earth
but what would this alien life look like
many scientists agree that whatever life
on Mars we might find would need to be
incredibly robust
with the combination of radiation and
freezing temperatures on Mars could any
life form survive such a harsh
environment
as far-fetched as it sounds
microbiologists have discovered many
organisms that thrive in extreme
environments
the tardigrade or water bear is a highly
resistant extremophile it can withstand
heat cold pressure radiation and even a
complete lack of oxygen
there are also certain types of bacteria
on Earth that rapidly produce spores
when faced with hazardous conditions
the bacteria can then hibernate during
an extended period of drought and
withstand intense ionizing radiation
a team of one thousand geologists
chemists physicists and biologists
worldwide have drilled 4.8 kilometers
into the Earth and discovered robust
life forms Mars has a similar geological
past to Earth so looking underground
could be a great place to start
by drilling into the gizero crater we
could encounter spores associated with a
relatively recent geological era and on
future missions to Mars we may dig
deeper and uncover fully vegetative
microbes
to find Rock's apples that might support
life NASA's perseverance Rover uses an
array of lasers called a super cam
it can study the surface of Mars at a
distance one of the lasers will heat a
rock sample and vaporize it this creates
a plasma that can be analyzed to
understand its Elemental composition
another laser will reveal which
compounds are in the dirt if the super
cam detects organic molecules or
elevated concentrations of elements like
nitrogen or phosphorus the Rover will
head over to take a closer look
it will then scan the soil in Greater
detail to detect any organic material
hiding in the dirt
NASA's team on Earth has only one shot
at picking the right spot to gather
these samples
with limited space on board the Rover
only a few dozen samples can be
collected
so no pressure and fingers crossed
if all goes well NASA plans to bring
back samples known for preserving
biosignatures on Earth
biosignatures are faint molecular traces
left behind by microbes billions of
years ago
once the samples are collected NASA and
the European Space Agency plan two
missions to get them back to Earth
this involves blasting tubes of rock and
soil samples into orbit to be collected
by another spacecraft and then return to
Earth
whoa this looks kind of fun
if perseverance's mission is successful
the discovery of Life on Mars would be
as groundbreaking as the discovery of
DNA
in 1543 Copernicus boldly shook the
status quo with his theory that the
planets orbited the Sun
his discoveries completely changed our
world view no longer putting Earth at
the center of the universe
discovering life beyond Earth could be
just as powerful
but not finding any life could raise
more questions
is the earth truly special are we alone
out here
even if we don't discover Life these
Martian Rock samples will allow chemists
to study the geochemistry mineralogy and
foundational Bedrock materials of Mars
in detail
this could provide us with essential
insights into the climate history of
Mars and help us better understand
Earth's climate as well
in 1976 two Viking Landers became the
first spacecrafts from Earth to touch
down on Mars
they too probed for life in the Martian
soil and the results are still debated
to this day
one experiment indicated that the
Martian soil tested positive for
metabolism on Earth this would almost
certainly suggest the presence of life
but another related experiment found no
trace of organic material whatsoever
While most scientists have not
reconciled the conflicting results the
consensus is that there's no conclusive
evidence of Life on Mars but several
researchers disagree
recent discoveries of terrestrial
microorganisms surviving outside of the
ISS indicate that life may be resilient
enough for Mars
and methane in the Martian atmosphere
could be a sign of microbial methanogens
a type of microorganism that produces a
significant amount of methane
stinky aliens
mind you it's possible that life on Mars
didn't have the right conditions to
start at all
or maybe it died off from an Extinction
event similar to the asteroid that wiped
out the dinosaurs
or it's even possible that we might end
up finding life that was accidentally
brought to Mars by one of our many
Rovers
let's hope this perseverance Mission
doesn't turn into a 2.7 billion dollar
face palm
if Mars is your bag well have you ever
thought about setting up shop there
with recent developments in rocketry
colonizing Mars might be possible in our
lifetime
[Music]
could there be an even better planet for
us than Earth
scientists are searching for a super
habitable world that wouldn't just rival
Earth but be a place where life could
Thrive even more easily
and they're looking at exoplanets
how would we discover earth 2.0
what would make an exoplanet habitable
and how long would it take to get there
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we discovered Earth 2.0
you wouldn't be able to find an
exoplanet by looking through a telescope
all you'd see is the bright glare of the
Stars they orbit NASA built the Kepler
Telescope to discover exoplanets and
before it ran out of fuel the Kepler
Telescope surveyed our region of the
Milky Way galaxy
its technology uses the transit method
to find planets hundreds of light years
away
how it measured the fluctuation of light
coming from distant Stars when a planet
transits or passes in front of a star
the star isn't as bright so the Kepler
telescope uses that to detect exoplanets
this is not an easy thing to do but
during its nine year lifetime the Kepler
Telescope confirmed the existence of
4367 exoplanets
could any of them be Earth 2.0
if you're a long time fan of what if
you've probably heard this before but
Earth is a very special place
and even if a planet is deemed to be
habitable it doesn't mean that it
resembles Earth very much a habitable
planet is a rocky planet located in the
habitable zone allowing water to stay on
the planet's surface in its liquid form
that's it Venus and Mars are habitable
planets but they are definitely not like
Earth
so let's talk about three major
conditions that we'd look for when
searching for an even better version of
Earth
first it would need to have sunlight our
Sun's lifespan is about 10 billion years
and it took 4 billion years for anything
more complex than the simplest life form
to pop up on our planet
but k-type dwarf stars have lifespans of
about 70 billion years so if we found an
exoplanet orbiting a k-type star there
would be more time for life to evolve
and live on it
the second major condition is
temperature
Planet that's too hot or too cold
wouldn't be able to host the life forms
we'd need to survive
but if we find a Planet that's a mere
five degrees warmer than Earth and it
has more water we could be looking at
Earth 2.0 covered in a lush biodiverse
rainforest
the third major condition we'd be
looking for is size
gravity retains a planet's atmosphere
and there's a direct relationship
between gravity and a planet's size
so if we find a Planet that's only one
and a half times larger than Earth it
would be able to hold on to its interior
heat and maintain its atmosphere for a
longer time
but bigger isn't always better
while earth-sized exoplanets are usually
Rocky about 50 percent of the exoplanets
larger than Earth are gas giants and if
an exoplanet is too small it would
likely be Barren like Mars
so are there any exoplanets out there
that meet these requirements
okay I found a planet that could be
super habitable
Kepler 1649c could be a contender to
become Earth 2.0
it's 300 light years away and orbits a
red dwarf star it gets sunlight but only
75 percent as much as Earth so it might
be a bit cooler there
and there wouldn't be any seasons on
Kepler's 1649c a full orbit only takes
19 and a half Earth days so we'd need to
get used to that oh and it could be
tidally locked which means one side of
the planet constantly faces its sun
while the other side faces space
also living on a planet that orbits a
red dwarf star could be risky
sometimes red dwarf stars send out
massive flares dousing an orbiting
planet in UV light and creating huge
temperature fluctuations
if we decide that Kepler 1649c
is worthy of becoming Earth 2.0
well using our current technology it
would take at least 2 000 years to reach
this Earth 2.0 and since this planet is
so far away we only know about its size
the distance to its star and the makeup
of its atmosphere
so we could pack up humanity take the
multi-generational trip to Earth 2.0 and
discover that it's more like a Neptune
2.0 uh yeah there's no way we could
survive on a gas giant we need much more
information before we send humans to any
possible Earth 2.0s
so right now NASA is developing a tiny
probe to travel at one-fifth of the
speed of light
it could greatly expand our knowledge of
exoplanets
and we shouldn't limit ourselves to
looking just at exoplanets
a moon receives direct solar energy from
its star and the planet it orbits
reflects solar energy toward it so maybe
a moon could be more suitable for human
life than an exoplanet the most
Earth-like planet in our solar system is
Titan Saturn's largest moon
so if we want to save thousands of years
of traveling maybe Titan could make a
good second home for us
[Music]
627 million kilometers from Earth
underneath the cold Seas of Europa a
horrifying and vastly intelligent
creature lurks
can our human Minds even comprehend such
an alien creature
uh actually yeah it turns out it's a lot
like an octopus
can Europa support life
would we go looking for it
and how crazy do we sound right now
this is what if and here's what would
happen if octopus-like creatures inhabit
Europa
okay we promise you we haven't
completely lost our minds
the idea of octopus-like creatures
inhabiting Europa comes from open
University professor of planetarian
Space Science Monica Grady
he says that says that below europa's
ice sheets aliens that resemble
octopuses May dwell
that gets the imagination reeling let's
argue for a second that this theory is
correct
Europa is one of Jupiter's 79 known
moons and is only 627 million kilometers
from Earth
it's covered in ice 24 kilometers deep
with the possibility of liquid water
underneath
this ice protects Europa from solar
radiation and asteroid impacts that's
all well and good but here's the kicker
it's
it's europa's ocean floor has
hydrothermal vents and sodium chloride
in the water
what does that mean well in short their
significant ingredients needed to
support life
Europa contains the essential
ingredients needed for life water
chemistry and energy
water is the big one because it
dissolves nutrients for organisms to eat
transports chemicals within living cells
and allows those cells to eliminate
waste
and Europa isn't exactly lacking in the
water department the ocean beneath the
crust contains more water than Earth's
oceans
and to argue the alien idea more there
may be a rocky seafloor that could
Supply chemical nutrients to living
organisms
and in this case it's the octopus
now octopuses are weird there's no
arguing that I mean we did a whole video
on it but some scientists say that
because the evolutionary step from the
nautiloid is so fuzzy the only
reasonable explanation is that they're
extraterrestrial
does that mean that they came from
Europa
if the news broke that we had octopuses
swimming up there on Europa how would we
react
well it would spark a massive push for
new space missions
if intelligent life like octopuses are
as close to us as Jupiter
what else is out there
may be a push to search for planets that
could support humans
but here's the downside the more we
venture into space
the greater the risks
I'm talking about bringing something
back now I'm not talking about the
xenomorph here I'm talking about a
harmful microbe or virus that may be
harmful to human health or even our
ecosystem we would need to put some
serious thought into the pros and cons
of regular space travel we would also
need to have advanced protocols and laws
to prevent contamination of both Earth
and other planets
because we deal with quarantines so well
right
so are there octopus-like creatures
living on Europa
I mean maybe
[Music]
we still think that octopuses are
Earthly even if they're a little weird
but even if there aren't any tentacled
alien neighbors we won't know until we
look
humans need to continue exploring space
I mean it is the next step
we are growing in numbers in mental
capacity and definitely in curiosity
but what if we didn't need to go looking
for these alien octopuses
what if they're already here
thousands of light years from Earth
there could be another planet hospitable
to life Kepler 69c
and you're about to travel to this alien
world to see that life with your own
eyes
what would it be like to make this Epic
Journey so far across the universe
what kind of planet would you be likely
to find upon arrival
and if you did discover Life what would
it look like
this is what if and here's what would
happen if there's life on Kepler 69c
located 2 383 light years from Earth in
the cygnus constellation is a potential
super Earth
at least that's what it's often referred
to as Kepler 69c is an exoplanet about
1.7 times larger than our planet
and it could also be around three and a
half times more massive
but there's a catch we don't really know
if this planet is located within the
habitable zone of its star
if it's too close
kepler-69c would be too hot for liquid
water to exist on its surface
if it's too far from its Sun well then
it would be nothing more than a frigid
world
what we do know is that Kepler 69c
orbits its star about 40 percent closer
than Earth orbits the Sun and that could
mean that it isn't actually a super
Earth
it could be a super Venus
so if you traveled all the way here
would you find life
or a thick scorching atmosphere boiling
every drop of water on the planet
before you begin your journey to Kepler
69c there'd be one very important thing
to keep in mind
it's far away almost 600 times further
away than Proxima Centauri our closest
neighboring star even if you could
travel say one percent of the speed of
light you wouldn't get there anytime
soon
at this speed you could whip around
Earth in just over 13 seconds but to get
to Kepler 69c well that would take you
about 238
000 years to even make this trip
possible you'd need a super Advanced
hibernation pod you know you don't want
to grow too old and die before you could
even get to your destination
am I right well hibernation technology
that could help you sleep for over 200
000 years doesn't exist yet but hey this
is what if anything's possible
by the time your ship makes its arrival
any life that may exist on Kepler 69c
today could evolve or Advance into
something entirely different
think about it this way 300
000 years ago humans were just beginning
to create stone tools and Spears
and look at you now making a trip across
the Galaxy
looking back at the planet you left
behind who knows what changes would
happen to our human civilization during
your trip
no matter what it's way too late to turn
around now
based on the planet's distance from its
star we know that Kepler 69c receives a
similar amount of sunlight as Venus
and despite being more massive than
Earth it has a relatively low density
all this means is that instead of metals
this rocky planet is made of silicate
and carbonate minerals
that could make things a little
complicated you see with all these
minerals in the crust Kepler 69c could
have a really thick atmosphere and to
make matters worse this atmosphere would
be composed mostly of carbon dioxide
oh did you choose the wrong super earth
to travel to
yeah if Kepler 69c is anything like
Venus it would be a pretty hot planet
all because similar to Venus its clouds
would trap the Heat and create an
extreme greenhouse effect
Kepler's 69c's atmosphere would be
caught in an endless cycle of getting
thicker and hotter
but nobody said this world should be
habitable for you oh no once you took
off your helmet you'd instantly melt and
suffocate
like I said life on this planet would be
completely different from what you'd
imagine
as you made your approach you'd find
surface temperatures as high as
475 degrees Celsius and the atmospheric
pressure would be over 90 times that of
Earth at sea level it would be like
being 900 meters deep in the ocean
except you'd be on dry land
with conditions like this you'd likely
not find anything resembling an ocean
here just like on Venus the high
temperatures would boil away all the
water
whatever life you could potentially
encounter on this planet it would need
to be able to survive in these brutal
conditions
or it would have to exist somewhere else
besides the surface
one place you could Discover Life on
Kepler 69c would be up in the clouds
around 50 kilometers up temperatures
would be much much cooler they would
range from about 30 to 70 degrees
Celsius and with its low density this
planet could have a surface gravity that
would be just over 70 percent of what's
found on Earth
this weaker gravity could allow life
forms to thrive in the sky where Kepler
69c is most hospitable
life could just be floating freely in
the atmosphere
this would be another way in which this
planet could have far more in common
with Venus than with Earth
probes around Venus have picked up
traces of a gas that could be a
potential sign of life phosphine if you
discovered phosphine in kepler-69c's
atmosphere it could be the result of
bacteria that don't require oxygen to
survive but be ready to hold your nose
this smelly gas has an odor similar to
decaying fish
on Earth the bacteria that produce
phosphine often live in swamps or
Wetlands but on Venus or kepler-69c this
bacteria could exist in the thick
oxygen-less atmosphere itself
so in the end you may have traveled a
very very long way to find the smallest
and stinkiest of Life Farms
now on the upside you've just discovered
extraterrestrial life
this not so little piece of equipment
could change astronomy forever and it
could be about to find alien life
maybe in a matter of days
what is this powerful new tool
how could it detect life in
far away
[Music]
let's find life
what would happen next
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the James Webb Telescope found
alien life
the James Webb Space Telescope launched
into space on December 25th 2021
its mission to study the history of our
universe
from the Afterglow of the Big Bang to
the formation of solar systems like our
own
this large infrared telescope is 100
times more powerful than the Hubble
telescope it has 18 separate mirror
segments made of ultra lightweight
beryllium
these unfold and adjust to form a six
and a half meter primary mirror
now that the web telescope has reached
its destination one and a half million
kilometers away from the earth it should
be able to see into the past of our
universe
it could be the key to discovering alien
life
unless they find us first
if you were looking for signs of Life on
distant exoplanets you wouldn't look for
little green aliens
you'd look for biosignatures
in other words characteristics in a
planet's atmosphere that could be
evidence of life in the past or present
imagine an alien astronomer From A
Distant Galaxy pointing a telescope
toward Earth
the biosignatures they make note of are
the presence of oxygen and methane in
our atmosphere without life forms
breathing these two gases in and out
these elements would react with others
and disappear
so the James Webb Telescope will look
for the presence of oxygen and methane
too
first you need to detect the presence of
an exoplanet around a distant star you
could do this through the transit method
as a planet passes in front of a star
you'd observe its light slightly
diminishing
after that planet passes in front of its
star many times you'd have enough data
to take measurements of its atmosphere
you'd be able to see how much light goes
through its atmosphere and you could
determine what atmospheric elements
exist there based on the way the light
disperses
with a telescope as powerful as the web
you could gather enough data after a
planet has passed its Star as few as
five to ten times
yeah so after only 20 hours of
investigating a planet you could detect
conditions for life
but then what 100 for sure gonna die
well you probably wouldn't go public
with this information right away
you'd probably want to follow the
confidence of Life detection scale
commonly referred to as cold
this is an approach that scientists at
Nasa are looking to establish
it would set up a new framework for
discussing how close we are to finding
life beyond our planet
the scale would have seven levels level
one would be the detection of Bio
signatures
as more data is collected you'd climb
the scale to level seven
at this point you'd likely find alien
life
and that's when the whole world freaks
out and Powerful aliens being down to
conquer our planet
right
not exactly
if we discover Life using the web
telescope it would be more than likely
that we are the powerful intelligent
beings
the bombshell announcement of alien life
would be a lot less dramatic than the
movies suggest
it could take decades be prepared for a
slow progression of countless mini
announcements
and remember that the distances between
Earth and exoplanets of Interest are
vast so if you decided to take an
Interstellar trip to one of those like
the exoplanet trappist-1e it would take
you decades
but scientists believe that this planet
may have atmospheric conditions similar
to ours or at least similar to the Earth
two and a half to four billion years ago
so maybe we could find microscopic life
there a discovery like this would elicit
many different reactions
for you it could be a dream come true
but for others it could be concerning it
could affect your entire understanding
of life in the universe
we might not be alone in the universe
scientists from all over the world have
their eyes and ears wide open trying to
detect signals of life beyond our planet
but we're a bit tired of just sitting
and waiting
so hop on our spacecraft because today
you have a very important mission to
search for alien life
how would we prepare for this journey
what kind of life would we be looking
for
and what would happen if we found it
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we went on a search for alien
life
so far we've detected over 4 000
exoplanets in our galaxy
and there may be as many as trillions
to make your Expedition easier you'd
need to consult with NASA first
NASA has developed the confidence of
Life detection scale or cold to measure
progress in life detection research
the scale has seven levels ranging from
signal detection to follow-up studies
once life beyond Earth is confirmed
first you'd need to look for Bio
signatures
this is physical evidence of past or
present life on another planet such as
chemical compounds or molecules that
indicate biological processes
if an alien astronomer was taking
measurements of Earth they'd look for
oxygen and methane those are
biosignatures that indicate life on our
planet
if you're a Celestial technology geek
you might scan for techno signatures
these are signs showing the negative
uses of technology that cause artificial
air pollution
this means aliens could figure out we
exist because of all that smog we send
into the atmosphere
embarrassing right now that you know
what to look for
where would you look for it
you could start this search in our own
Cosmic backyard alien life could be
hiding on the subsurface oceans of
Europa one of Jupiter's moons or deep
beneath the surface of Mars ground
telescopes have already detected methane
on Mars sending probes to measure
surface levels
that already puts you on the second
level of the cold scale or you could go
further and look for alien life on rocky
planets outside our solar system you'd
need to locate planets orbiting a star
in its habitable zone that's the area
where a planet is not too close to the
star and not too far allowing for
temperatures to be just right for liquid
water to form
scientists have already done the hard
work for you here
using the Kepler object of Interest
exoplanet archive researchers identified
systems that might have rocky planets
that meet the criteria they found 24
super habitable planets
and one of them is very promising koi
5715.01 is roughly 1 billion years older
than Earth
which means it's had enough time for
life to develop
scientists estimate that the best chance
of discovering life is on planets
between five and eight billion years old
that makes koi
5715.01 a perfect candidate now while
it's a bit cooler than our planet it
could support life if it contained
enough greenhouse gases
okay so let's say you detected bio
signatures on koi 571 5.01 now you've
got yourself a potentially habitable
exoplanet NASA would then have to
confirm that there were no measurement
errors and that the planet really has
the potential to host life
The Next Step would be to predict what
type of source could generate such a
signal
scientists would need to confirm this
signature couldn't have come from a
non-biological Source once that was done
you'd be on level 4 of the cold scale at
this level scientists would test the
signal with other Advanced measurement
methods
NASA's powerful James Webb Space
Telescope would confirm the exoplanet
contains a strong signature for life and
you would be able to proudly say you
found alien life
and then scientists would be able to
kick-start follow-up studies at level 7.
that means you'd now be ready to fasten
your seat belt and see these aliens for
yourself
but how would you get there
yeah that's when things get tricky koi
5715.01 is located almost 3 000 light
years away from us that's 700 times
further away than Proxima Centauri the
closest star to our solar system
if we used developing ionic propulsion
engines it would take over 55 million
years to get there
you'd have to make use of some
futuristic Solutions like a laser sale
this technology uses ultra thin mirrors
to capture the momentum of light from
stars and then uses this momentum to
push a spacecraft to high speeds
if you managed to build laser sails with
diameters of 320 kilometers you might be
able to reach koi 571 5.01
in about 8 500 years
setting aside the fact that you wouldn't
live that long
what would you find once you got there
alien life could be extremely complex or
very basic and the alien's appearance
would depend on the world they evolved
on
things like gravity density and the
amount of energy given off by its star
they would probably have something that
resembles fingers or tentacles to build
tools and since two legs and two arms
are more efficient than four legs the
aliens might have evolved to walk
upright
you want to invite them for a stroll
well first you'd need to figure out
their form of communication
and it might be a little more advanced
than speech or writing they might just
exchange pheromones or even use
telepathy
and finally you'd want to know how they
reproduce
we can't be sure if alien reproduction
happens by seeding fishing or egg laying
so maybe it's best to leave the romantic
stuff here on Earth
while your journey to find alien life
might be successful in our hypothetical
story
in reality it's still very far-fetched
with technology evolving to detect
signals from outer space we might be
able to identify them at some point but
there would still be the issue of
getting to them
what good does it do knowing something
is out there if we can never see it up
close
I mean unless aliens were already living
inside Earth
but that sounds like a story for another
what if
[Music]